مشاهدينا الكرام كما اشرنا وجود مراسلينا
في اكثر من موقع يعطينا صوره اوليه عن
القصف الفلسطيني او قصف المقاومه
الفلسطينيه للمستوطنات والبلدات والمدن
الاسرائيليه في العمق وصلت الى حوالي 60
كيلومتر شمال قطاع غزه وصولا الى مدينه تل
ابيب كما نشاهد على الخريطه اذا كانت هذه
هي مابات يعرف بدائره النار الفلسطينيه
التي تم تنفيذها اليوم والتي استمرت او
تواصلت من جنوب تل ابيب كما نشاهد على
الشاشه استمرت كل هذه المنطقه هي دائره
النار اليوم التي وصلت الى حوالي 60
كيلومتر شمالا وايضا شملت مستوطنات او ما
بات يعرف بمستوطنات غلاف غزه هذه المنطقه
التي تمتد من عسقلان وتصل الى اشكول بعمق
حوالي اربعين كيلو متر من قطاع غزه وهذه
النقطه التي تمتد الى حوالي
كيلو متر او خمسه وخمسين كيلو متر من قطاع
غزه لتشمل هذه العمليات العسكريه
الفلسطينيه اليوم في الرد الاول على مقام
به الاحتلال من قتل 13 فلسطينيا اكثر من
400 صاروخ وفقا ما اعلن وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي هذا اليوم اكثر من 400 صاروخ
اطلقت من قطاع غزه كما اشرنا القصف بدرجه
اساسيه توجه نحو مناطق جنوب تل
ابيبسيون ووصل الى بيت شيمش في المنطقه
الغربيه من القدس المحتله وايضا امتد الى
محيط مطار بن غوريون وشاهدنا حركه الطيران
التي توقفت في مطار بن غورن الذي يقع في
مدينه اللد داخل الخط الاخضر واصبحت حركه
الطيران في المناطق الشماليه فقط ومنع
تجوال الطيران فرض ما يشبه بحظر طيران في
المناطق الجنوبيه بعمق اربعين كيلو متر
ووزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي كان قد قال بان
هذه التحركات او هذه الاستنفار الام تصل
الى عمق 80 80 كيلو متر اذا ما تحدثنا عن
80 كيلو متر فنحن نتجاوز تل ابيب بعشرين
كيلو متر نحو الشمال قبل حيفا بين حيفا
وتل ابيب هذه حيث وهنا تل ابيب بين حيفا
وتل ابيب نتحدث عن 80 كيلومتر هذا يعني
مساحات واسعه من اراضي داخل الخط الاخضر
ستكون تحت ضربات النيران اذا ما استمرت
هذه المواجهه اذا ما انتقلنا الى صوره
اقرب لمبات يعرف بغلاف غزه فنحن نتحدث عن
هذه المناطق من عسقلان الى ازديروت واللقب
الغربي وصولا الى اشكول في المنطقه
الجنوبيه هذه المستوطنات حوالي 55 او 50
مستوطنه يسكنها حوالي 55 الف مستوطن تشكلت
هذه المستوطنات بعد الانسحاب الاسرائيلي
من قطاع غزه عام 2005 بعد ان انسحبت قوات
الاسرائيليه من قطاع غزه واصبح قطاع غزه
تحت السيطره الفلسطينيه الخالصه تشكلت هذه
المستوطنات هذه المواقع بعمق حوالي 40
كيلومتر وتتكون بدرجه اساسيه من ثلاث
مجالس استيطانيه هي مجلس مستوطنات اشكول
في المنطقه الجنوبيه ومجلس مستوطنات شعر
هنيجر في المنطقه الشرقيه الشماليه
الشرقيه ومجلس مستوطنات
في المنطقه الشماليه هذه المستوطنات كانت
اليوم في دائره القصف الفلسطيني بدرجه
اساسيه وسقطت الصواريخ في هذه المواقع
وطبعا بطبيعه الحال تاخر الرد الفلسطيني
خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه انعكس
ارتباكا شديدا في المشهد الميداني
الاسرائيلي وتم عمليا اخلاء عدد كبير
وكبير جدا من المستوطنين من هذه المناطق
لينتقلوا الى مناطق العمق الاسرائيلي خلال
الساعات القليله الماضيه وفرض ما يشبه
بحذر التجول في هذه المنطقه التي تتجاوز
كما اشرنا حوالي اربعين كيلو متر او من
الى اربعين كيلو متر داخل العمق
الاسرائيلي على الحدود مع قطاع غزه قبل
قليل شاهدنا ايضا الصواريخ التي سقطت في
مدينه اسدود كما نشاهد على الخريطه مدينه
اسدود في المنطقه الشماليه التي لا تبعد
الى حوالي 30 كيلومتر فقط عن قطاع غزه
وشاهدنا اثار الدمار الكبير الذي حدث في
مدينه عسقلان الى شمال قطاع غزه حوالي 17
الى 20 كيلو متر فقط بين قطاع غزه وعسقلان
عسقلان التي يسكنها حوالي 150 الف
اسرائيلي مدينه عسقلان الكبرى التي يسكنها
حوالي مئه 120 130 الف فلسطيني في مدينه
عسقلان استهدفت اليوم بشكل مباشر وشاهدنا
الصور قبل قليل لسقوط صواريخ واصابتها
بشكل مباشر لمباني في مدينه
عسقلان كما تبعنا قبل قليل الصواريخ
الفلسطينيه اذا كما تحدثنا هذه منطقه
الاستهداف حتى هذه اللحظه منطقه النار كما
اشرنا تبرز في المناطق الجنوبيه من تل
ابيب اسدود عسقلان النقب الغربي او ما بده
يعرف بغلاف قطاع غزه في مدى لم يتجاوز حتى
الان 60 كيلومتر ولكن وفق التقديرات
الاسرائيليه اذا متواصلت هذه العمليات
العسكريه فان المدرسه يصل الى 80 كيلو متر
وهذا يعني توسيع دائره الاستهداف المقاومه
الفلسطينيه للاراضي والمواقع الاسرائيليه
في العمق الاسرائيلي اذا ما استمرت هذه
العمليه العسكريه